hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about the news that came out
yesterday from astrazeneca
that they have now initiated their phase
one clinical trial for monoclonal
antibody combination
for the prevention and treatment of
covert 19. so the aim of this phase one
clinical trial is to assess the safety
tolerability and pharmacokinetics that
is
what the body does to the drug to see if
there's a generation of any anti-drug
antibodies
and the drug that they'll be using is
asd-7442 which is a combination of two
monoclonal antibodies
so what are these mono-colonial
antibodies going to be doing
well the aim of astrazeneca is to
develop a drug
for the prevention and treatment of
cavite 19 so the aim of this drug
is to prevent infection of healthy cells
by the cells called two virus
and whilst it still wasn't completely
understood how this virus is infecting
healthy cells it is pretty well
established
that the way that it's doing it is
through the use of spike proteins
on the surface of sarcophagi and these
spike proteins contain
a receptor binding domain that can
interact with
ace2 receptors on healthy cells to
enable us integration
into healthy human cells so a desirable
goal would be to
block the receptor interaction of the
spike protein with the ac2 receptor
so what do we know about the antibodies
that estrosenica are going to be using
well earlier this year astra seneca
signed an exclusive license to six
candidate antibodies
currently from the vanderbilt university
and they had a nature paper out earlier
this year where they screened lots of
different
potential coronavirus neutralizing
antibodies that
bind to the receptor binding domain on
the spike protein
so astrosenica are going to take two of
these monoclonal antibodies from the six
and progress them into clinical
evaluation as a combination approach
within the next two months
so fast forward two months and here we
are with the two chosen
monoclonal antibodies that astral seneca
further developed
to improve the half-life and according
to their press release the half-life
extended
monoclonal antibodies should afford at
least six months of protection from
covid19
and the other neat thing to notice about
the antibodies is the fact that it's a
combination
it's like a cocktail of two different
antibodies and
the reasoning behind this is based on
the fact that by having two monoclonal
antibodies that bind to distinct parts
of the sars cop2 spike protein
it is hoped that it could improve the
effectiveness of neutralizing the virus
and prevent entry into healthy cells
so this phase one trial is going to
include 48 healthy participants in the
uk
aged from 18 to 55 and so it is hoped
that
based on these results that have an idea
of the tolerability and safety profile
of the drug
and if it's good news then ashley
cenaker will progress it into larger
late stage phase 2 and phase 3 trials to
evaluate its efficacy as a potential
preventative and treatment approach
against covert 19.
so as always i hope you've learned
something and thanks for listening